newly arrived at a Red Cross center in
Belgium from the Syrian city of Aleppo
with fresh tales of atrocity the
merchants are ethnic Orthodox Armenians
caught between the bullets of the other
sub regime and disparate rebel groups
fighting it very 19 my own world is
neighbors we don't know in the morning
go go out to one if you will back or no
we don't know how can we go out from
Syria the family paid eighteen thousand
dollars to be smuggled into Turkey than
three days to Belgium by truck hidden in
a secret compartment then a long wait
for a decision on their asylum request
it's so hard from because we are in
stress and before we are in the stairs
and come at now we are in the stress
yeah because we got to start go out and
start new life long waits years not just
months will be a thing of the past after
em eps passed a package of measures
making the entire process for asylum
seekers quicker fairer the conditions of
reception far more humane europa no de
sel vista como el policia case pulsa a
loss in mere antes vamos a destruir con
esta legislation el automatism accrual a
new mono new measures include six months
for a decision under most circumstances
better reception conditions and prison
detention as a last resort part of a
common European asylum system that MEP
is like Cecilia wickstrom have been
fighting for for years I have personally
seen people shaking those bars screaming
help me help me I need protection in
Europe all the more relevant as far as
she's concerned in view of continuing
atrocities in Syria it's a mass
slaughter going on in Syria so what the
European Union can do is to accommodate
and give protection to those that that
may enter here but keep in mind that not
everyone can flee from Syria today back
in Belgium is steep and Binoche is
hoping for a speedy result he's a
diamond setter and hopes he and his
family will soon be moving to the
world's diamond center not far away in
Antwerp
you